from Selena Gomez and the weekend to
kendall Jenner and Drake Hollywood is co
chillin in the desert Coachella weekend
one is going down in Indio California
right now any tea is keeping up with all
the actions can't keep my hands to
myself Selena Gomez and the weekend were
inseparable during the Travis Scott
concert Friday night Selena kept things
low-key and a white tee jeans and
Sonny's while her beau wore an all black
get up and shades while Kendall Jenner
attended the same concert showing off
her assets her BFF shared this post to
Instagram rocking this sheer ensemble
and Thaung celebs like Drake French
Montana and Katy Perry are also among
the famous faces at the event headliner
Radiohead suffered major technical
difficulties during their set Friday
night and walked off stage twice a
source at the festival tells ET quote
the audience was so confused and shocked
people were clearing out and leaving
before they actually finished we can't
wait to see what day two holds
[Music]